hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem multiply strings
so we're given two non-negative integers
num1 and num2 but these could be
extremely large numbers and because of
that these integers are going to be
represented as strings as you can see
down below and the good thing is that
these integers are always going to be
either positive or they could be zero
and we want to just take these two
numbers multiply them together get the
product and then return that product as
a string and we're not allowed to you
know actually do this with integers
right we can't just convert these two
strings to integers we actually want to
do this with strings themselves because
you know there's no guaranteed that an
integer this large could actually fit
into a 32-bit or a 64-bit integer and
they don't want us to use any kind of
big integer library so there's going to
be two parts to this problem the first
part is going to be to remember how you
actually multiply two numbers in the
first place you probably learned it in
elementary school but you may have
forgotten so that's the first thing we
need to figure out how to actually
multiply two numbers and the next part
is how can we actually take that idea
and then translate it into code in a
readable and you know somewhat concise
way and that's going to be the second
part that we have to figure out and just
to go through an example real quick you
can see 123
456 you multiply those two together you
get this value and we are returning it
as a string so let's go back to
elementary school how can we take two
numbers like these and multiply them
together in a formulaic way that we can
translate into an algorithm well
remember we usually first start with the
ones place over here right and then we
just take this value and then multiply
it by three multiply it by two and
multiply it by you know the more
significant digit and then we add those
three together you know we also do have
a carry which is something we're gonna
have to keep track of and you can kind
of tell that you know if we take six
multiply it by these three integers then
we're gonna go to four we're gonna go to
five multiply it by these three integers
then we're gonna go to four multiply it
by these three integers that's something
that could probably be translated into a
nested for loop right so we're kind of
learning that as we go but let's just
start with this so six times three
that's going to be 18 right but normally
you know we just take the first digit
eight put it over here in this ones
place then we take the one and carry it
right so the one is going to go up here
it's going to be added to whatever goes
down here but in the code we're actually
going to be putting that one here
immediately
because you know when we're when we're
keeping track of a carry we could keep
track of it over here like in a single
variable but it's kind of just easier to
just put it here because we know it's
going to be added with whatever next
value that we put over here so next
we're going to look at 6 multiplied by 2
that's going to be 12 right so we're
going to take 12 add it with the carry
right that's going to give us 13 in this
position right so we have a 3 digit here
and we have the 1 which is going to be
the carry in the next position now
notice how when we were multiplying
these three together we put the digit in
the first spot but when we multiply
these two together we put the digit in
the next spot and when you multiply
these two together we're gonna put the
digit over here so basically the way you
know how we decide where we actually put
the digit when we multiply two digits
together is basically going to be the
sum of the indices of these two so
basically consider this is zero this is
one this is two these are the indices uh
if we're multiplying these two together
we're gonna put it but we're gonna put
the digit in the zero position if we
multiply these two together we're gonna
take zero plus one we're gonna put it in
the one position over here now if we
multiplied these two values together
we'd say one plus one
you know
these two multiplied together we'd put
the digit over here because this is the
two spot i know that's kind of tricky to
you know recognize immediately but i
think it makes sense because you know
when we're multiplying six by one we're
not actually multiplying six by one
we're multiplying six by a hundred right
because this one's place is in the
hundreds place so that's kind of the
intuition behind that but yes now we
take six multiply it by one we get a six
right so this is where we would put the
six we clearly have a carry over here so
we're gonna actually put a seven over
here so so far this is our result but we
only went through this six digit next we
want to go through this five digit and
multiply it by these three values so we
take 5 multiplied by 3 we get 15 right
the 15 is going to go in this
spot over here right but of course we
have a carry one over here so what are
we gonna do well we're gonna take these
add them together and we're gonna take
these add them together right so we're
gonna get an 8 over here and we're going
to get an 8 over here next we're going
to take 5 and multiply it by 2 and the
position that that's going to go in is
going to be in this position right
because
you know that's just kind of the math of
how these indexes add up so 5 times 2 is
going to be 10 so we put a 10 here right
0 plus 8 that's just going to stay 8 but
that one carry is gonna go over here in
this position notice how the result when
you multiply two numbers the number of
digits in the output could be greater
than the number of digits in the input
now what's the maximum number of digits
the output could even be well if we took
two numbers suppose 99 multiplied by 99
right these are kind of the biggest
integers we could have for two digits
each how big would the output be well
the output would be four digits i think
it'd be something like something like
this i'm not 100 sure on that but
basically you can see that you know if
we have two digits multiplied by two
digits the max the output could be is
the sum of the digits of each of these
right so if we have an example like this
one three digits multiplied by three
digits we could have an output of up to
six digits but it might it could be less
than that right for example you know you
take 10 multiplied by 10 we just get a
three digit number 100 right even though
two plus two is four digits this is the
output happens to be three digits so
it's it's basically going to be less
than or equal to the sum of the number
of digits but okay so where did we leave
off we were gonna now multiply five by
this one and then put it in this digit
position because this is that index two
this is at index one so
the output is going to be at index three
over here right these are kind of the
indexes of the output so five times one
is just going to be five so we take a
five here add it with the one that's
already there so we're going to get a 6
in this position by the way notice how
when we count the indices where you know
this is 0 this is 1 this is 2. so
basically the integers themselves we're
going to be iterating through them in
reverse order similarly we're going to
be building our output in reverse order
as well and then at the end we're gonna
take this and reverse it okay so now we
took five multiplied it by all three of
these digits so we're done with five
lastly we're going to take four and
multiply it by all three of these so
four times three is going to be 12 right
we're going to put a 12 here you know we
take these two add them together we're
gonna get a zero in this spot right a
zero and we had a six here we had a one
here now we're gonna since we got a zero
here we're going to have another one
carry in this position so when we
actually add these together we're now
going to have an 8 in this spot so we
took 4 multiplied it by 3 now take 4
multiply it by 2 which is going to be 8
and we're going to put that a in this
position because that's how the math for
these indexes adds up so 8 plus 8 is
going to give us a 6 so we can put a 6
here but of course we're going to have a
carry right 8 plus 8 is 16 so this is
what we have we had to put that carry
over here so we took 4 multiplied it by
2 lastly we're going to take 4 multiply
it by 1 and then put it in this spot so
4 plus 1 is or 4 times 1 is 4 so we take
a four add it here add it with one we
get a result of five and then we're done
right because we took four multiplied it
by this multiplied it by this and
multiplied it by this we we finished our
nested for loop and this is the result
that we got
and as you can double check that matches
exactly with the output that they
expected so basically how i ran through
it is similar to exactly how we're going
to code this up the only difference is
we're going to pre-create we're going to
pre-allocate the result array in this
case we have three digits by three
digits so we're gonna have an output
array and we're not gonna keep track of
it in terms of strings even though the
input is given to us in strings we're
gonna build the output as an array just
because it's a little bit easier i think
you could do it with a string but then
we'd have to do a lot of conversions you
know converting a character to an
integer and vice versa doing it as an
array is a little bit easier and then at
the end we can take the array and then
convert it back into a string you know
pretty easily so that's kind of what
we're going to do and like i mentioned
we're going to start at the right
position of each string at the right you
know in reverse order we're going to
iterate through the input strings in
reverse order and when we build the
output you know this is kind of the
order of the value we're gonna build it
opposite we're gonna put the eight here
because this is index zero we're gonna
put another eight here zero six five
right so as you can see this is
basically built in reverse order to this
so we're going to do that but then at
the end we can take this array reverse
it and then convert into a string which
is going to look something like this and
then we can return the string in the
format that they actually wanted and the
last thing is when we're when we're
taking two digits and multiplying them
together consider if we had the largest
digits consider if these digits were
actually nine and nine right we're only
multiplying one digit by one digit so
the max that this could possibly be is a
two digit value in this case nine by
nine is going to be 81. so when we take
when we we're always going to want the
ones place right to actually put it in
this spot right so when we take a value
like 81 we can mod it by 10 to get the
ones place which will give us 1 and we
can divide it by 10 to get the carry
right so if we divide this by 10 we'll
get 8 because it always rounds down in
most programming languages right so
that's how we're going to do the math on
that we're going to put the 1 here then
we're going to take the carry put it in
the next spot right add it to the next
spot and in terms of time complexity the
since we're going to be doing a nested
loop it's basically going to be let's
say n times m where n is the number of
digits in the first value and m is the
number of digits in the second value
that's overall going to be the time
complexity i think the memory complexity
is going to be something like n plus m
because we're going to be using an
additional array just to have all of the
output digits inside of it then convert
it to a string at the end with that
being said we can go ahead and dive into
the code so now let's finally write the
code and the first thing i want to do
before actually dive into the actual
algorithm is basically uh if either of
these digits or these numbers happens to
be zero then we can just return zero
itself right but then we don't actually
have to execute our code so one way in
python i can check that is if this is in
the array with two values num one or
num2 basically i'm checking if either of
these values happens to be zero in which
case we can return zero right any value
multiplied by zero equals zero the other
thing is allocating that array right so
i'm going to allocate an array of all
zeros multiplied uh or basically the
length of this is just going to be the
length of num1 plus the length of num2
and as i mentioned we're going to be
iterating through both numbers in
reverse order so before i actually
iterate through them let me just reverse
each of them and this is basically how
you reverse in python i'm sure you can
do it in your own language of choice and
we're going to iterate through both of
these keeping track of the indices right
because we know that the index is going
to be useful for some of the math that
we're going to have to do so for i1 in
in
range
of the length of num1 so i1 is going to
be the pointer for num1 and i2 is going
to be the pointer for num2 now we want
the digit right so we're going to take
the numbers or the digits from each
number and then multiply them together
we know the digit itself though could be
a two digit value so let's keep that in
mind so the digit from num1 multiplied
by the digit from num2 and so where
exactly are we gonna store this digit
well you might remember i mentioned in
the drawing explanation we're going to
take the indices i1 add it with i2 which
is going to tell us what position to put
this in the output result so we can then
store this digit there but remember we
have to mod this digit by 10 before we
actually store it here and we might not
just be storing it there might have
already been a carry in this position so
we're going to add whatever this one's
place is to whatever is you know this
target position so that's where we're
gonna add the ones place digit now we
might have a carry the carry might be
zero or it might not be zero either way
we're going to put it in the i
you know the position plus one right so
just the next position over is where
we're going to put the carry value so we
can add the carry value to this position
we can calculate the carry value by
taking digit dividing it by 10. and the
last thing is i didn't mention but
suppose we were given two values 10
times 10 in this case we would have our
output end up being something like zero
a hundred the reason we have a leading
zero is basically because you know when
we allocated the output array we took
the digits
two digits here two digits here so we
would have a four digit result so we
basically want to get rid of any leading
zeros which is something we can do
pretty easily so before we try to get
rid of the leading zeros let me actually
reverse this result so result is going
to be set to itself except reversed and
the beginning pointer is going to be set
at the beginning of this result and
we're going to keep incrementing
beginning while it happens to be zero so
while beginning is less than the length
of the result and
the value in the beginning position
happens to be equal to zero basically
while we have leading zeros we're going
to increment our beginning pointer until
the point that we don't have any leading
zeros anymore now we do have an array of
integers not an array of strings so in
python at least there's a way that we
can convert this
we can use a map function and basically
convert every single a value in this
result from the beginning pointer all
since we calculated the beginning point
we're just going to be you know we're
basically removing the leading zeros by
doing this uh operation starting
basically taking the sub array starting
at the beginning pointer and we're
converting each integer to a string at
least that's how we're doing this in
python i'm sure you could write out the
two lines of code that it would take in
other languages so once we convert the
array to an array of strings then all we
have to do is just join the strings
together and python you can do it
something like this just join it with an
empty string and one thing i forgot is
first of all i named this num i just
changed it to num2 and since these are
actually you know characters we have to
convert them to integers before we can
multiply them that's something i usually
forget i don't know if you guys forget
that as well but let me actually convert
them to integers first and actually one
other thing that i forgot and this is
actually a good example what if we had a
let's say we had a two in the ones place
and then two this two we're adding a
digit of we had an eight and we're
adding a digit of two right so you know
that's kind of what i'm doing with this
line of code in that case we would have
a two digit value here right a ten so
we'd have to take this whatever stored
here and then mod that or rather divide
that by ten to see if we have a carry
resulting from two ones place digits
that's something we were handling in the
drawing picture but i forgot about that
when we were actually writing out the
code so the way we can remedy that is
basically when we're going here uh we're
gonna take just the digit itself and add
it to this position right the digit
could be a one digit value like two or
it could be a two digit value like 12
right either way we're adding them
together and then it could be possible
we have a two digit value stored here
right so one thing we'd want to do if we
did have a two two digit value and
stored it here we would want to take it
and mod it by 10 right so basically set
this equal to itself but modded by 10 we
can do that pretty easily right right so
we're just taking it modding it by 10.
if it just happened to be a single digit
value like 2 then it would remain the
same if it was a 2 digit value like 12
then we'd get the ones place and put it
here but notice how we're doing this
after
we're doing this line because this line
of code actually is going to be similar
because before we do that we have to
take the carry that could be stored here
right like i said it could be a two
digit value like it could be something
like a 12 in which case
we'd want to take this value divide it
by 10 and then add it to the next
position over right so we're taking the
carry adding it to the next position we
can get the carry by taking this two
digit value dividing it by 10 and then
adding it to the next position i know
this might have made things a little bit
more confusing so sorry about that but
you know if you kind of do go through
these three lines of code run it on an
example on your own you'll see that it's
pretty much exactly what i was doing in
the drawing explanation so as you can
see this code does work so this is the
entire code i hope that this was helpful
it's definitely not super easy to get
here but i do think being able to
understand you know how multiplication
works is a very good first step in being
able to tackle this problem i think
using an array also makes things a lot
easier so i hope this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon thanks for
watching